معنى من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العميد الياس حنا سابدا
عميد الياس بتعليقك على مجريات الامور من
الناحيه الميدانيه فكيف تقرا المشهد
الميدانيه
عثمان هناك ثلاث جبهات مهمه جدا
ليست هناك من حركيه مهمه هناك هجوم وهجوم
مضاد المعركه او المطحنه البشريه هي كانت
في سوليدار وتدور اليوم حول مخموت محاوله
لتطويقها من قبل فاجنر وبمساعده القوات
المحموله الروسيه ولكن الشيء الجديد وهو
امر يعني بديل تقريبا هو ما يجري في
زباروجا وكاننا نرى عمليه تحسين المواقع
التكتيكيه تحضيره لمرحله قادمه لانه
بالمعنى العسكري وبال امكانيات وبال دراسه
الارض وطبيعه الارض المرحله القادمه هي
المرحله الاساسيه والواحده قد تكون في ذا
فروجها الارض سهله مهمه مهمه جدا
للاوكرانيين ومهمه جدا للرؤوس الدفاع عنها
او حتى استرداد بارودها لانها تعتبر من
ضمن الاقاليم الاربعه
ضمها الرئيس بوتين هذه هي ولكن ليس هناك
من هجوم كبير جدا القوات لدى الروس
ليست جاهزه لعمليه كبيره حتى الان
القوات الامريكيه قرر الرئيس بايدين ان
يمدد
وجودها وانتشارها في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
حدث عادي غير مفاجئ ام له اهميه خاصه
له اهميه ولكن هذا امر اصلا موجوده هذه
القوه
جنود في شرق همم اوروبا الشرقيه تقريبا
تدعيم ما يقارب ال 100,000 وعدنا الى ما
قبل يعني خلال ما قبل سقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي وكاننا في حرب همم بارده جديده
او تطبيق جديد هذه القوات موجوده من
القوات المحموله المئه وواحد وهي مهمه جدا
لانها عمليات جويه تخلق الدفاعات وهي ليست
بعيده عن الحدود الاوكرانيات 100 كيلو متر
تقريبا هي موجوده عمليه تبديل وهي رساله
علنيه ايضا لزياده نوعيه الردع او حده
الرد عليه القوات الروسيه
بشكل عام ايضا كيف تقرا هذا الجاده بين
حلفاء اوكرانيا انفسهم فيما يخص امدادها
بالاسلحه والدبابات الثقيله
الدبابات الثقيله عثمان مهمه جدا للمرحله
القادمه انها اساسيه للهجوم لدى اوكرانيا
اليوم ما يقارب المئتين مدرعه عربات مدرعه
يستلجم وراءها دعم مدفعي وصدم هذه
الدبابات تامينها الموضوع والخلافه على
الايباد 2 حتى الان المانيا ولكن هناك حدث
بسيط مره كخبر يقول ان هناك طواقم
اوكرانيه تتدرب على الليو بارك تشغيلا
وتعهدا في بولندا وكاننا بانتظار ان تعطي
هذه الدبابات سواء قبلت المانيا او لم
تقبل وقد حدث او يعني قال هذا الامر صرح
بهذا الامر الرئيس الوزراء البولندي منذ
يومين تقريبا رئيس الوزراء الهولندي
ماتريوس مرافسكي همم يقول انه يعني قد
يكون هناك تحالف اصغر
بعيدا عن ما يصفونه في بولندا بالموقف
الالماني
تردد هل ترى ان هذا قد يحدث قريبا ومن هي
الدول التي يمكن ان تشكل هذا التحالف
الاصغر على حد وصفه
عندما ننظر الى ااا اوروبا عثمان هناك
الدول الكبرى لهذه روايه كما يقال فرنسا
المانيا وهي المتردده اكثر من غيرها وهناك
اوروبا الشرقيه المحازيه لروسيه وهي التي
تعتبر ان امنها القومي مهدد بشكل مباشر
نتحدث عن دول البلطيق نتحدث عن رومانيا
نتحدث عن هولندا قد يكون هذا الامر من ضمن
هذه الدول الدبابات ليفار او غيرها خاصه
ان هناك 2,000 دبابه لدى حلفاء امريكا ب
13 دوله منهم ضمن نيته ومنهم خارج نيته
ولكن الاكثر حرجه وتضررا هي الدول
المحاذيه للروسيه بين البلطيق هولندا وحتى
رومانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك الخبير العسكري العميد
الياس حنا متحدثا الينا من بيروت